michael pineda been on the il some this
year so his record just three and four
no down at the bottom walk strikeouts he
has always had
good control first pitch strikes
and he's going to have to locate his
fastball in and out which is a key for
him and then he's got that very good put
away hard slider
here's the pitch
blooped out into center and it's going
to get in there for a hit and not a
great read by gordon the center fielder
that ball landed just a few feet in
front of him but you could tell he just
didn't get a good look at it and that is
a lead off single
live ball center field
and gordon coming in making the catch
right off the end of the bat
and gordon who's got great speed needed
some of them to get to the fly ball and
the 01 pitch a fly ball into right
playable for kepler
back a step or two over to his left
he'll call and catch it above his blue
cap so brill flies down harmlessly to
right
anderson remains in first base two outs
no score one and one on goodwin whether
it goes and the pitch inside rorvette to
second base simmons the catch the tag
and they got him another great throw
from the rookie ben rortvet anderson
caught stealing simmons caught the throw
and a quick tag down in the head first
sliding anderson and he is out number
three lancelin has had a remarkable year
as era a touch over two looking for his
ninth win today a lot of strikeouts very
few walks right-handers left-handers
alike they just don't hit him very well
and it's not like it's a secret what he
throws arises oh for eight that's
probably the most surprising stat in
here kepler oh for six is not as
surprising cruz just one for five so
he's handled some pretty good hitters
well
that's a fair ball down the line arise
banks one off the sidewall and he's
going to dig for second and the throw by
goodwin is not in time luisa rise
doubling right over the first base back
the rise now four for nine in this
series has been tremendous when hitting
first in the lineup now polanco
first pitch cutter floated to left billy
hamilton is there to make the catch
we've seen with larnick he really is
susceptible to off-speed pitches that's
not really lance's game but that's the
weakness of learning
on the ground second base garcia gives
some ground and the runner arise gets to
third but you can tell early on the
twins are being very aggressive with
lancelin well they know lance has really
good control i mean he was a twin at one
point so they're familiar with his
tendencies and now you got to get by
cruz rise at third two outs no score and
the one-two pitch a fly ball into right
field playable drifting back is goodwin
near the wall pulls it down and that's
the inning twins ways to lead off double
do not score a rise
on a fastball to left field larnick is
back he's not going to get there it's
rolling all the way to the wall at angle
we'll chug into second base with the one
out double good matchup you say huh good
matchup it was a very good matchup and
adam
welcome back to the lineup with a
ringing double now leori garcia with a
runner in scoring position and one out
the pitch
a drive deep right
way back there and it is gone
a two-run homer for garcia
sox have the early lead two-nothing just
the third home run for liuri and it
comes at a great time he's driven in 36
runs this year he got out ahead of a
slider and you could tell by kepler
taking a look at it drifting back there
park was never going to hold this one so
ringing double and now with two run
homer and the sox do indeed have an
early lead
warnick up right deep in the box slight
open stance
and hit in the air well to center field
long run angle back on the track to the
wall
good a solo homer for trevor learning
seventh of the year twitch trail two to
one yeah middle of the plate a little
below the belt good extension through
the ball hit it a long way and learning
now with eight and this is a one run
game two out for rortfat
swing and a miss weren't that late on a
fastball
they get the lead off homer from larnick
but lynn works around two walks they
strand both billy's going to lead off
the fifth with a hard hit line drive to
left and that's over larnick
billy hamilton into second base with a
leadoff double
billy the hitter giving it to i think ta
yeah probably tim because tim's a guy
that encourages him and tells him you
just don't have to be the runner and the
defender anymore and bear in mind this
is righty righty after the injury he
decided to swing only right handed which
means he's facing right hand pitchers
from the right side for the first
extended time in a long time so with the
sacrifice hamilton to third tas two for
two we'll see how pineda pitches him
tried to get in on a change up and that
was a bad idea tim anderson three for
three hamilton scores and tim's into
second base standing up and he did not
get a real big secondary lead it was
just a mediocre lead if he was going on
contact they'd have probably thrown him
out at the plate if it was right at an
infielder key batter here as zavala goes
out to the mound
two on two out for nelson cruz who's
only seen six pitches today here we go
the pitch
cruz pops it up
shallow center field who wants it
a shortstop anderson he's got it
twin strand two
off to the sixth the guy with the
homer's at the plate garcia he's two for
two here's the pitch
driven out into right center that ball's
in there
let's see if leori can get to third
angle will score
relay throw to third late it's a triple
we've got a cycle watch yes we do as
laori traded places with adam engel and
gives the next batter jake berger the
opportunity to drive him in without the
benefit of a hit infielders in against
burger
fly ball well hit deep right center it
will get off the wall
here comes garcia berger has a double
a double burger
5-1
yes indeed as it's a double run here in
the sixth inning as well
anderson is third two outs here in the
seventh the batter is goodwin
one two ground ball into left base hit
anderson scores goodwin's going to try
for two and he's gonna make it
it's six to one
well that's timely right after the
double play for goodwin to deliver the
double two down and here comes billy
hamilton
2-2
and
check swing roller to third and
hamilton safe at first that was a very
strange play did that pitch at the dirt
i don't know as barrel was down by the
plate that just fits right in with the
legend of billy hamilton he hit a one
hopper didn't mean to swing didn't mean
to hit it and then head to speed to beat
it out this is amazing he's
he's the very happy man right now but i
don't think you see this very often two
outs bottom of the nine
two and two
simmons pops it up
right hand side
andrew vaughan makes the catch and the
sox have won the series in comeback
fashion
and right now are up seven and a half
games in the american league central